道は
おっ
yeah
ふーん
goo
分
hey
yahoo
たくさんつけちゃったこんばんは初めて像だよ
いない
ロースがツンなろうそく好きかねうううう茎ぶごぶこ立つんが特産どう使うと合っ
ちゃっさ
ここまでで皆さん気づいているかどうかはわかりませんがこのろうそくすべて
はいこわかりでしょうかねわかってるとも言いそうなんだけどこれで偽物なんですけど
後ろが電源式になってて
落ち着けるとめっちゃくちゃろうそくに見えるって言う大きいものでそんな偽物だろう
探さ300買いましていて朝すでにこんな曲となら近いずかしいでバレると思うんです
けども普通に1個だけポイントいって言ったらマジでろうそくに見えるんですよいや
本当は本文でやりたかったんですけどもんすいませんねばいい youtube さん
が厳しくておそらくいい
出てこんだけほぼのろうそくたいたらもう火事みたいになっちゃうのでダメですと言う
けど偽物を準備させていただきました
あっつくないんですよねサーこんな沢山の62個使って何をしろと言いますとろうそく
といいでもう一羽一危ないんですよ
例えばこれがで本物のろうそくで10てこういうリストがについては伊勢燃えますから
ね試験なんですさん
ロウソクの火だぞ言ってもとっっっても危険後受けて金がいないでしょうかと言います
とこれは偽物だからこそできるドッキリしよう
と思います後輩の k スケベが今家の前に車が止まっているのでそのグループの中に
今の体重が300のろうそくを那賀高
いい感じに排出しておきますそしてろうそくを設置し終わった後ターゲット車に呼び
ますあー
車が燃えとるねー
といって彼は車に戻ってしまう車ん中を見てみるとあら大変車の中がろうそくで弾い
はいもしこれが本物ってこれだけのろうそく車にあったら間違いないと思いますもう
透明でこのロックみたらマジで本棚と思うんで
そして車の中大量のろうそくだらけだったらどういう反応するのか継承していきたいと
思います皆
税
はい本物のろうそくでやらないでねマジで本当に燃えるから本当に偽物だったらいいよ
やばいやばいはやばいやばいやばいやばいなーぐっ1せ光が注いでふーん
して
実はこの勃起をするのに最適なところがあるアノード車の鍵を
関係はせる月会え庁議で早速元がを見ていきましょう
何やまのこないで暗くなる前になるべくを設置できればなと思いますどんどん仕掛けて
いきましょう
[音楽]
ん
あのと骨車の鍵かけなすぎなんですよね
ねこれを機にね車の鍵ちゃんと書けなきゃなって思ってくれると嬉しいです
[音楽]
今近所の人があったんですけど本物です勝って待つが割れました
これはひっかかりますね
me
ハピバースデー p 2
言う言う
はいというわけでご覧くださいクール学んでいいです
は軽い人ですああじゃあでもちょっとテンション上がりますね
普通のイルミネーションだったらテンション上がるんですけどものって本人はこれがで
本物のロウソクとと思ってくるんでマジで焦ると思いますほぼ勝ちです
[音楽]
サーマルで300歳の誕生日を迎えてしまったようなターゲットくるなぁ交流を見た駿
果たしてターゲットはなんと言うのでしょうか分からないです
非常に気になる所ですねばクラックなってターゲットが来るのを待ちましょう
[音楽]
ん
モイ
ドローンを待って本体の線これでっ
私はヤバイってくるマナカチでヤバイかつてやバイクと思う
以下でロって待って本子じゃ
[音楽]
ルーシーっ
car
うううう
me
re
大阪でもう一度乗ってるとっきーでしたねうん
まず済んだと思うん